فقدت مصادر احاديه للجزيره ان الجيش
التركي
استهدف بالمدفعيه الثقيله مواقع ما تعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه في قرى عده على
امتداد الطريق الدولي ام 4 الشمال الرقه
واوضحت مصادر الجزيره ان القصف طال ايضا
مواقع لتلك القوات في قرى اخرى بريف تمر
شمال الحسكه وقالت مواقع عالميه مواليه
لما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه ان
قاصفا مدفعيا تركيا
عين العرب على الحدود السوريه التركيه
هذا وقد وصفت الخارجيه الروسيه لعمليه
البريه التركيه المخطط لها في سوريا
بالخطوه السابقه لاوانها وبانها قد تؤدي
الى مزيد من القصيم وقالت ان هيئه الاركان
العامه واجهزه الاستخبارات في البلدين
تجريان لاتصالاتهم مكثفه بشان العمليه
العسكريه التي تعتزم تركيا القيامه بها في
سوريا
واشارت الخارجيه الروسيه الى ان موسكو
تتعامل بفهم مع القضايا الحساسه لحمايه
الحدود التركيه الجنوبيه
لكنها تنطلق من الحاجه الى التقيد الصارم
بمبادئ وحده اراضي الدوله السوريه
واستقلالها وسيادتها